leur confinement comme réponse à
l'aggravation de la crise sanitaire
sera-t-il un coup de grâce pour
l'économie le premier confinement
s'était soldée par une chute historique
de l'activité aux conséquences
désastreuses
un choc dans l'économie commençait tout
juste à se remettre alors la france
peut-elle en supporter un deuxième avec
tel coût économique et social
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bienvenue
jacques un bonjour olivier alors jacques
leur confinement en vigueur depuis une
semaine maintenant nous renvoie t-il à
la situation du printemps dernier oui
absolument si d'ailleurs on peut bien
écouter ce qu'on dit que ce soit jérôme
salle au moment où le ministre de la
santé
mais on sait aussi que tout le film en
aura des conséquences graves que ses
conséquences soient économique social
sanitaire ou psychologique c'est
pourquoi on sent bien que le
gouvernement si on regarde les mesures
veut désespérément ne pas tuer
l'activité et pourtant les mesures qui
sont prises et l'incertitude qui règne
autour de ces menus de ces mesures aura
de toutes les manières des conséquences
extrêmement négative et profondément
durable sur l'activité économique
alors jacques peut-on estimer ses
conséquences oui tout à fait les mesures
de couvre-feu qui avaient été prises il
ya maintenant en plus de quinze jours on
savait qu'elle allait coûter grosso modo
1 % de croissance à l'économie française
avec les nouvelles mesures
on estime que le coût sera au minimum de
2 % et si ces mesures devaient être un
petit peu prolongé dans le temps
assis confinement devait durer un peu
plus que quatre semaines et bien on
pourrait monter jusqu'à 4% alors c'est
important parce qu'il faut savoir que
avant le confinement avant le couvre-feu
on était déjà pratiquement à des % de
chute de la production pour l'année 2020
et on voit en particulier sur un
graphique qui mélange à la fois des
données qui sont réalisés par le fonds
monétaire international et
des données qui ont été recalculées dans
mon laboratoire on voit que en fonction
des hypothèses que ce soit quatre
semaines huit semaines où que ce soit
justement une prolongation avec
possiblement une troisième vague au
printemps
eh bien on atteint des résultats qui
sont bien plus mauvais alors d'ailleurs
depuis ce confinement les protestants
les commerçants par l'ong proteste
beaucoup oui oui et non sans raison
d'ailleurs ce nouveau coup d'arrêt sera
fatale à un grand nombre de pme savez il
n'y a pas moins de 200 milles commerces
qui ont été fermées administrativement
et on le sait que beaucoup n'y
résisteront pas pourtant on disait que
l'économie était en train de se
redresser
oui tout à fait effectivement l'activité
économique avait semblé se redresser de
rendre cet été seulement il faut savoir
que l'insee indiqué il ya quelques jours
déjà que cette reprise de l'activité
flée crise est déjà en septembre est
nettement plus mois d'octobre même chose
si on regarde le graphique
eh bien on voit que les y est les
commandes de biens durables commencé à
baisser en septembre 2020 par exemple
les dépenses de consommation des ménages
en biens s'était fortement repliée et on
voit que ce repli provient
essentiellement de la baisse importante
des achats de biens fabriqués de biens
manufacturés
un chiffre qui a baissé d'environ 7%
donc il est évident que tout cela
repousse et déjà le redressement total
de l'économie bien au delà de 2024 et
est ce que l'on peut détailler par
secteur d'activité la kia oui oui bien
entendu
alors d'abord il ya évidemment le
secteur du commerce à ça on l'a dit mais
il faut savoir que cet impact sur le
secteur du commerce aura évidemment des
conséquences sur l'industrie qui fournit
les biens qui sont vendus par le
commerce et donc sur la production et
sur l'emploi se lance il sera pas le
seul
évidemment le secteur du tourisme et de
la restauration sont aussi sinistrée on
peut étendre ce réseau non au secteur du
transport aéronautique d'ailleurs les
commandes d'airbus sont passés de 776
avion en 2019
seulement 300 cette année et enfin il ya
toujours la question du télétravail le
regard sur le gouvernement veut
favoriser le télétravail mais on sait
très bien que les entreprises sont très
réticentes et pour une raison très
simple c'est que le télétravail amoindri
la productivité et donc en réalité
amoindri la production 1 mais le
gouvernement entend bien prendre de
nouvelles mesures de soutien non oui à
bruit absolument le fait que les
commerces depuis ce plus en un souffle
et les commerces de produits
alimentaires et qui plus est dans une
période où ça va être noël évidemment on
s'attend à ce que les ventes soient très
important bien tout cela va créer une
crise de trésorerie très importante dans
les tpe et dans les commerces une crise
que le gouvernement cherche à éviter par
des mesures spécifiques
alors ces mesures on sait qu'elles
comprennent la prise en charge de 10000
euros par mois de la perte de chiffre
d'affaires des tpe pme qui ont été
fermées administrativement
il y aura des mesures de prêts pour
soutenir justement ces entreprises en ce
qui concerne les chars et les loyers à
payer dans ces périodes et enfin on
parle beaucoup d'un plan pour les
indépendants les commerçants et les tpe
mais là encore il faut faire attention
parce que d'abord les prêts ce n'est pas
de l'argent direct et puis ensuite parce
que le gouvernement n'a pas détaillé son
plan spécial et surtout n'a pas abordé
le sujet des pertes d'exploitation qui
sera un sujet évidemment très important
dans les semaines qui viennent
et selon vous jacques est ce que le
gouvernement a pêché finalement par
manque d'anticipation
oui oui que je pense que c'était tout à
fait évident alors on le voit déjà avec
la manière dont le gouvernement n'avait
pas prévu cette fronde des commerçants
et la fronde des maires inquiets eu lieu
le week-end dernier au delà vous savez
quand emmanuel macron utilise des
métaphores militaires dans des livres
nous sommes en guerre comme en mars
dernier où quand ils utilisent
l'expression de couvre feu
tout simplement il a oublié ou peut-être
n'at-il jamais su comment on gagne une
vieille vous savez olivier une guerre ça
se gagne en constituant des réserves que
ce soit en sommes au matériel et ce sont
ces réseaux
justement qui peuvent être engagées
quand la situation se dégrade comme
aujourd'hui donc il fallait dès le
printemps dernier
commencer à penser à la constitution de
ces réserves que ce soit en lions
respiratoires ou en personnel justement
et accumulé juste des moyens qui
pourraient être engagés maintenant quand
on voit que emmanuel macron et le
gouvernement mais ils sont restés
fidèles à modèle de gestion lui inadapté
et je dois dire que au delà des erreurs
qui ont été commises dans la gestion au
jour le jour de l'épidémie c'est
probablement là que se situe l'erreur la
plus grave et du coup quels seront les
effets durent confinement sur les
inégalités
si vous voulez il est évident que tout
confinement accroît les inégalités
alors vous avez un rapport du conseil
d'analysé économique qui a été fait il
ya quelques jours et qui établit par
exemple que dans l'épargné importante
qu'on a cumulé les français on parle
autour de 55 milliards d'euros cash et
bien grosso modo 70% de cette épargne
sont réalisés par les 20% les plus
riches
a contrario les 50 % les plus pauvres
les dd des ménages eh bien eux ils ont
vu leur épargne diminué donc ya déjà une
égalité de revenus évidente et puis ya
toutefois les autres inégalités comme
les inégalités de logements les
inégalités qui viennent dans la
répartition du travail est là dessus est
aussi une note de la direction du trésor
qui détaille la totalité de ses aînés
gâté oui on peut dire que le confinement
c'est un accélérateur des inégalités il
va donc falloir s'attendre à un
quatrième semestre noir
oui c'est aujourd'hui une évidence c'est
le choc de ce deuxième confinement sera
lourd alors entre 2 et 4% du pipe c'est
évident bien sûr un choc aussi en
matière de chômage ou peut penser que le
chômage va augmenter
en plus de ce qu'il a devait augmenter
avec les effets du premier confinement
de 200 mille voire trois cent mille
personnes et donc on aura un recul de la
production qui va se situer entre -12 et
-14% pour cette année par ailleurs il
est très clair que l'on ne retrouvera
le niveau de 2019 en 2023 ce qui étaie
l'hypothèse du gouvernement mais qu'il
faudra attendre très probablement 2025
c'est considérable
mais il faut savoir que ce n'est pas le
pire ce n'est pas le pire que voulez
vous dire par l'ajac
mais si vous voulez le pire c'est que
l'incertitude qui est engendrée par la
situation actuelle
justement par cette deuxième plaque et
par le fait qu'on se demandait ce
qu'elle ne sera pas suivie à près d'une
troisième vague
et bien cette incertitude est les
meurtrières pour tous les projets
d'investissement que ce soit les projets
d'investissement des entreprises
mais que ce soit aussi les projets
d'investissement des ménages
or si vous voulez c'est l'investissement
privé qui est d'une certaine manière
l'un des moteurs avec la consommation
bien entendu de l'activité économique
si on a pas d'investissement eh bien ça
veut dire qu'il n'aura pas de véritable
reprise en 2021 2022 war 2023 c'est pour
ça qu'il est tout à fait capital
aujourd'hui que l'investissement publics
prennent massivement le relais de cet
investissement privé qui sera défaillant
du fait de l'incertitude et que l'on
aille bien au delà du plan de relance
qui a été annoncé plan de relance qui
s'avère désormais obsolète et
tragiquement insuffisant il faut bien le
dire
alors le gouvernement à vous entendre et
donc au pied du mur merci en tout cas on
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
jacques